[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition de votre journal
d'information locale nous sommes le
mercredi 23 novembre voici lé titre le
mois sans tabac bientôt terminée
l'opération pour lutter contre le
tabagisme court jusqu'à la fin novembre
au centre hospitalier de versailles et
des tabacologues sont présents toute
l'année pour accompagner les fumeurs
dans leurs démarches nous avons suivi
l'une de ces consultations
animations débats ateliers la sixième
édition des rencontres kreactive se
tenir à montigny le bretonneux une
nouvelle journée dédiée aux
entrepreneurs au féminin avec comme
thème cette année les ressources enfin
dans ce journal vous découvrirez le
nouveau visage de la mairie de saint cyr
l'école après dix mois de travaux et un
investissement de près de 800000 euros
le nouvel hôtel de ville a été inauguré
hier mais on ouvre ce journal avec la
ville d'elancourt une nouvelle fois
décoré pour son école numérique le maire
les républicains de la ville jean michel
fourgous a reçu aujourd'hui le prix
territoria d'or par l'observatoire
national de l'innovation publique
ce prix récompense investissements
d'elancourt dans le numérique
2500 tablette équipe notamment les
établissements de la ville ce nouveau
prix et la 23e récompense au palmarès
d'elancourt
dans le reste de l'actualité le mois
sans tabac arrive bientôt à son terme
c'était initiative portée par le
ministère de la santé consiste à
encourager les fumeurs à stopper la
cigarette durant un mois cela
permettrait de multiplier par cinq les
chances in fine et d'arrêter de fumer à
au centre hospitalier de versailles un
service tabacologie existe depuis le
début des années 2000 nous avons assisté
à l'une de ces consultations reportage
deux semaines avec un patch une bonne
dose de volonté et l'envié de retrouver
un souffle normal s'il ya 20 ans a
décidé d'arrêter de fumer
progressivement de 15 à 8 cigarettes par
jour une évolution positive est
importante même si les difficultés le
sont aussi je me sens respirer je me
sens humaine et voilà la difficulté face
aux lyonnais a tout le temps il y en a
partout et dans tous les domaines
et voilà ça fait partie de du sevrage
que ce soit tabagique alcooliques ou de
drogues donc il ya des difficultés mais
quand on atteint nos objectifs on est
hyper content pour réussir son pari
célia consulte le service tabacologie du
centre hospitalier de versailles une
aide essentielle qui doit lui permettre
d'éviter la rechute à long terme moi je
prenais la cigarette comme une amie
carrément c'était vraiment je l' âge là
je dis je l'humaniser et est donc c'est
vrai que c'est pas facile de séparer
jean amis quand il ya des rechutes elle
est essentiellement due à la dépendance
psychologique c'est à dire que la
dépendance physique et
a disparu la dépendance comportementale
aussi est il ya une émotion qui va
revenir et qui va faire rejeter les
spécialistes parlent d'art et confirmé
après deux ans sans cigarettes chaque
année en france 73 mille personnes
décèdent à cause du tabac
hier dans les locaux de promo paul à
montigny le bretonneux se tenait la
sixième édition des rencontres kreactive
le réseau d'entrepreneurs au féminin une
édition axée cette année autour des
ressources qu'elles soient matérielles
ou immatérielles
reportage
qu'elles soient chefs d'entreprise ou
porteuses de projets des entrepreneurs
yvelinoise rencontre généralement les
mêmes problématiques identifiées
mobiliser les ressources pour réussir
c'était le thème de cette 6e édition des
rencontres kreactive cette année l'idée
c'était de parler des ressources toutes
les ressources qui peuvent nous aider en
tant qu'entrepreneur à se développer
donc les ressources personnelles que
l'on peut avoir pour chacun d'entre eux
mir les ressources matérielles la marque
par exemple la valorisation de
l'entreprise les ressources matériel
informatique les logiciels non si les
financements c'est important pour cette
journée créactive ateliers tables on
était organisée dans les locaux de promo
paul la pépinière d'entreprises saint
quentin en yvelines comment recruter
efficacement faut-il externaliser
certaines ses tâches des questions des
réponses qui ont trouvé un écho
favorable auprès des participantes donc
moi j'ai lancé mon entreprise je suis
tout seul donc on a toujours besoin
effectivement d'échangés de 2 vous de
partager des idées avec les autres c'est
une très bonne initiative ça permet à la
fois de faire connaître ses produits de
pouvoir donner du conseil d'être à la
rencontre de ses clients en direct et
puis c'est extrêmement convivial c'est
une ambiance très agréable donc
s'il ya une très bonne initiative vouée
96 femmes sont membres de l'association
créée actifs fondée en 2004 tous les
mois des rendez vous ouverts à tous sont
organisées par la structure
à saint cyr l'école le maire l'est
républicain de la ville bernard de bain
a inauguré lundi la nouvelle le nouvel
hôtel de ville le bâtiment a été rénové
durant dix mois pour notamment être mise
aux normes pour les personnes à mobilité
réduite avec par exemple un ascenseur
une large verrière a également été
construite dans le nouveau bâtiment coût
total des travaux sept cent soixante
quinze mille euros dont 50 % à la charge
du département des yvelines écoutez à ce
propos le maire de la ville bernard de
bain on avait organisé les bureaux on a
amélioré l'accueil de façon à ce qu'il y
ait plus de confidentialité quand les
gens viennent à l'état civil avant
c'était ouvert ma pensée des bureaux
fermés c'est quand même
beaucoup plus aptes à remplir les
missions qui nous sont demandés on
estime toujours que pourquoi le maire
fait des travaux à la mairie et non
paille mais c'était non seulement
nécessaire mais pour se conformer à la
loi sur l'accessibilité
c'était de toute façon obligatoire
depuis plus de 40 ans l'association
plaisir oise lecture et dialogues
propose des conférences autour des
ouvrages en présence des auteurs jeudi
dernier l'une d'entre elles s'est
déroulée à la clé des champs deux
plaisirs françois guillaume lorrain
écrivain et journaliste de
l'hebdomadaire le point en était l
invité il venait échanger autour de son
nouvel ouvrage ces lieux qui ont fait la
france reportage de mélanie poquet
c'est le récit d'un périple d'un voyage
à travers l'hexagone le romancier et
journaliste françois guillaume lorrain a
cherché 26 lieux qui ont marqué
l'histoire de france je travaille en
fait sur la sur la mémoire des lieux
ayant fait sur les traces que laissent
l'événement l'histoire quand elles
arrivent dans ces lieux
depuis donc le moment ou à l'événement
jusqu'à aujourd'hui il y avait des
incontournables c'est à dire des mythes
pour nous dans notre imaginaire comme
marignan comme comme bouvines ce soit en
des batailles comme valmy com après il y
avait des petits plaisirs que je voulais
m'offrir je voulais refaire la fuite du
roi louis saez havane je veux savoir
exactement comment ça s'était passé ce
drame pourquoi il est s était arrêtée
qu'est ce qui s'était passé dans cette
rue des recherches faites au fil de ses
articles pour l'hebdomadaire le point
ces lieux qui ont fait la france sort en
2015 l'auteur le présenté jeudi dernier
à la clé des champs de plaisir ce sont
des conférences sur des sujets divers et
variés qui peuvent se rapprocher si vous
voulez ses choix des sujets historiques
soient des sujets spur dit tes ratures
pur nous en recevons des écrivains qui
nous parle de tout leur cursus
choix scientifiques soit c'est très très
variable la prochaine conférence se
tiendra le jeudi 24 novembre
il y sera question de philosophie
changement on enregistre le week-end
dernier était lancé l'opération coude
yvelines la gastronomie est mise à
l'honneur jusqu'au 27 novembre
visites thématiques cours de cuisine
marché de producteurs locaux de
nombreuses animations sont proposées
nous sommes allés suivre l'une d'entre
elles à plaisir sur la culture du thé
reportage de patrick jacques de dixmude
et camille lambert
qui a beaucoup de bien donc il verrait
chanter mais il a des propriétés pour le
coeur il est d'appliquer
cardiovasculaires ils aident à la
digestion ki moon hop huairou darjeeling
le thé noir sabine bataillait en connaît
tous ces bienfaits responsable d'une
boutique spécialisée à plaisir elle
anime un atelier de dégustation une
activité proposée dans le cadre de
l'opération good yvelines pour apprendre
les vertus et propriété de cette boisson
on a des thés blancs qui sont très doux
on a des tevere qui ont des prêts pure
était très tournée vers le bien-être et
la détente on a des thés semi fermenté
qui ont une complexité aromatique qui
sont assez peu connue type le aux
longues on a des thés fumée qui sont
idéaux pour un repas on a des thés comme
le cuir sont des tessons breton était de
garde qui ont des vertus qui sont même
entrés dans la pharmacopée chinoise et
plein de bonnes vertus c'est complexe
c'est difficile d'affronter quelqu'un
vous un tordu c'était là elle vous
expliquez vous les fait goûter c'est
plus simple température qualités de
l'autre temps d'infusion plus qu'une
culture en quatre mille ans la
consommation du thé est devenu un art en
france deux personnes sur trois on
consommerait et pour les amateurs le
bonté est à étudier de la même manière
que le bon vin comme beaucoup je pense
que je prends le même t tous les jours
et que je voulais m'ouvrir à d'autres à
d'autres sensations à d'autres à
d'autres goûts j'ai eu l'impression de
faire une dégustation comme une
dégustation de vins où justement on nous
fait passer les différents degrés du 20
au 22 voilà voilà les différentes années
voilà good yvelines se poursuit jusqu'au
27 novembre avec plusieurs rendez vous
gastronomique le programme est à
retrouver sur internet préparez vos
papilles
on referme ce journal avec du sport et
l'organisation aujourd'hui d'une après
midi sportive sur les de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines la structure a
accueilli pour la première fois depuis
2003 un cross départemental unss
plus de 2500 jeunes âgés de 13 à 18 ans
ont participé à l'événement au total dix
courses à pied en pleine nature de deux
à quatre kilomètres étaient programmés
on écoute l'une des organisatrices de
l'événement alexandra sa madness elle
était au micro de miquel et demi d'euros
alors c'est un gros événement puisqu'il
rassemble plus de 2500 élèves sur tout
le département des yvelines nos classes
et 92 à 100 établissements qui sont
concernés on a autant des établissements
du coin c'est à dire des établissements
de maurepas trappe voisins le bretonneux
que des établissements qui viennent de
mantes la jolie où de rambouillet
l'objectif du cross départemental dans
un championnat départemental
ça veut dire qu'il est qualificatif pour
le championnat académique qui lui sera
qualificatif au championnat de france
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi rendez vous demain aux
horaires habituels pour une nouvelle
édition de votre journal local bonne
soirée à tous
[Musique]